beans to talks close by Gregory Sadler
on what kind of all period and some
abdominal segments if I'm Khawaja watch
watch on physical appearance moral
character however we begin with Gregory
Sadler from marist college hood and his
title again is what kind of moral theory
distant and family hold and we have what
45 minutes reach papers so you pop that
up questions and then so you're going to
make some chives back and forth benedict
ins and lancets probation today has
actually the feast of Saint Anselm so
I'm very happy to be giving the paper as
on his feast day Anselm of Canterbury
famous to philosophy for his so-called
ontological argument is less well known
for his moral theory equally worthy of
attention revealing itself too attentive
study that surprisingly rich original
what I intend this paper to do is to set
up some main lines of an Psalms moral
theory motivated by providing an answer
to the question what kind of moral
theory Disney on some whole can we
effectively located under a rubric
typically disgusting contemporary
classes literature like utilitarianism
of the anthology virtue ethics like or
does it effectively fuse together
elements or aspects of such moral
theories or is it perhaps to engineer us
to find any such categorization perhaps
challenging the addressee of such class
victori schemes to obstacles block the
path to providing answers to these
questions one of these is the
unsystematic nature of the anthems will
applaud is observed in writing which you
never consolidated into treaties
resembling ourselves naked mccain
extra pounds ground work so well must
weave together threads running through
his treatises the letters the Vita the
dicta and saw me even as prayers and
meditations in order to generate a full
view his moral theory there is however
one central point around which meant the
many aspects of his moral theory
constantly one concept and experience
that is rectitude or rightness of will
kept for its own sake which has done
boucher observe appears alongside it
col- Koga Terry non potest as one of
state Ansel's most central thoughts you
see this as we go through his works
reoccurring but this formula requires
considerable unpacking and specification
which one needs to do following lines
and some tents all set out again in
multiple and unpredictable locations so
first of our categories are the good one
central aspect any moral theory involves
the basic good or Goods the theory
recognizes and values what does it hold
to be good how does an order or arranged
goods in relation to each other what
good if any does it ascribe priority to
is the most valuable is fundamental even
as the basis of other goodness Anselm's
works contain numerous recognitions of
references to and distinctions between a
surprisingly broad and rich variety of
goods can we reduce these to some sort
of general classification in the mobile
ogod says to himself you are accustomed
to consider nothing good except on
account of some usefulness or on account
of intrinsic goodness giving health and
what conduces to health as examples of
the former and beauty and what
contributes to beauty of the ladder all
goods in this view are either useful
goods that is valuable and typically
will for the sake of something else or
intrinsic finesse them Goods valuable
and will for their own sakes around
their own accounts the motive odeon
treatment also introduces several other
important and selling and doctrines
including the notion of distinctively
different degrees as opposed to mere
quantities of goodness or greatness
reflected not only in subjective
evaluations but objectively in the very
being of things he argues for an
ontological
goods on other goods ultimately on
divine goodness which later he tells us
is a dynamic unity of whatever it is
better to be the not to be included
supreme wisdom truth goodness beauty
greatness and justice among the other
divine attributes just as importantly he
Accords to reason not only a capacity to
discern between and ordered goods and
values but also a normative requirement
to employ this capacity record he says
for a rational nature being rational is
nothing other than being able to
distinguish to just urban on just the
truth from the non true to good from the
non good and the more good from the less
code ultimately this apprehension of
values assumed not only cognitive or
inferential but also effective and
cognitive forms already the insults
earliest work with lips that human being
is called the distinguish and act upon
their distinctions between different
kinds and degrees of goodness
understanding and framing these perhaps
by reference to a divine source and
exemple our boots so what additional
lighter clarity dudes subsequent work
spring skipping over day Barry tante for
the moment in de Libertad a the
distinction between goods will for the
sake of other things and goods will for
their own sakes gets revisited framed in
terms of whether one can will something
unwillingly in some respects that is
whether one can have a will divided
against itself in over several objects
Anselm uses health as an example of a
good will for its own sake with drinking
absinthe which we probably wouldn't
associated with health these days but
they did back then as something will for
the sake of health indicating that
something like health might be regarded
in certain situations or by some persons
as an intrinsic good by others is merely
useful or instrumental considering a
forced choice between willingly end of
magnitude of will or willing to preserve
one's life or safety and some introduces
another important consideration the
unavoidable necessity to choose between
different goods to order them to prefer
to prioritize the theme he expands in
the day including a bully and some
introduces further refinements bearing
on goods in the will Network most
notably by distinguishing between two
fundamental and determinative
orientations of human or any other
rational beings of all angels fallen
angels any other conceivable rational
beings the will to happiness and the
will to justice in later works and some
consistently refers to these as in the
nations or dispositions of the will
affect Sione's distinguishable from the
will is instrument as well as the
particular willings is use of that
instrument which are conditioned by
these wills as inflammations the will to
justice can be lacking or present in a
person but the will the happiness is
always present enacted although not
always specifically configured in the
same way the what the happiness he says
is a natural will for avoiding the
detrimental and for having the
beneficial this involves willing those
things and conditions which one
considers in some way to be beneficial
to oneself willing happiness and to be
happy and whatever is regarded as
conducive or necessary to realizing such
desires a thing may be beneficial in
different ways one thing is beneficial
he says through its use or when used
another through what it brings about
still another through both the category
the beneficial of us almost entirely
encompasses the previous distinction
between useful goods valued for the sake
of other goods and intrinsic goods value
for their own sakes I had that qualifier
almost because although the category
that beneficial includes the entirety of
useful a portion of intrinsic goods fall
within another distinct category the
good of justice so this is the second
part France all justice is a different
higher more valuable kind of good than
the others which we've explored thus far
justice in the full and primary sense of
the term rightness or moral goodness the
Justice which
says should be praised and whose offices
should be condemned the Justice which is
quote that very good through which
people are good and I'm kind of which
the will is said to be good or just
exists or does not is present or absent
within the will of a rational being
correspondingly he says injustice is
that very evil which we say is nothing
other than privation of the good or as
he adds the absence of a justice that
has been abandoned since other than in
the other than justice or injustice
nothing is called just or unjust except
for the will or on account of the
gesture unjust will the justice or
injustice the specifically moral
goodness or badness of other things
including these are examples he uses
actions hearts person states of affairs
even the kernel appetites resides not in
them but it derives from the Wills
relation to them justice and an psalms
thought is the specific modality of
goodness of rational will can possess a
goodness qualitatively greater than the
goodness of beneficial goods and thus to
be preferred to valued more highly than
merely beneficial goods or even
happiness in fact a rational being want
to have justice in its will and insofar
as it lacks justice it is to that degree
or in that way unjust not as it should
be not as it was meant to because the
language that Anselm uses constantly
motion of Deborah the rational being
received a free Faculty of Allah
precisely for the purpose he says of
willing what one should with it that is
justice and justly but then what is
justice absolutely answering this from
an Anatolian perspective requires a
step-by-step process of setting up
formulations which integrate with each
other one first step is to say that
justice is doing or willing what went on
to that is willing or act in accordance
with some sort of identifiable rule or
standard and lying in the situation or
to use the alternative formulation
Anselm employs than poised what is
fitting setting aside for the moment the
issue of precisely how one determines
what one want to do or little one can I
ask as Anselm has a student do the day
very taut a is this all there is to
justice following a set of rules or
commands willing to do the right thing
in the situation then the answer is
known for handsome in order to be just
one must not only will the right thing
but also will it because of one should
or more simply expressed because one
should the reason why one will something
matters if one were to will what is
right solely because of the apprehension
desire and pursuit of her jump
production of the beneficial like a dog
for instance these this example loving
its puppies through instinct there is no
justice in a willing reaction although
there is to be sure goodness if one
wills and does what is right out of
vainglory or simply to avoid punishment
again at least in a very tante in the
person's will there is thereby no actual
justice one must will the right thing as
the right thing because it is the right
thing not because of beneficial goods
our happiness one also necessarily
desires and Will's aunt's home seems is
intransigent and uncompromising as
content as point when one wills justly
one wills he says rectitude of will
catch for its own state which is in fact
his definition of justice whatever
whatever other objects the will may have
or desired it must also intend this one
more justice is lacking in the person
who is willing often there exists
compatibilities between these
motivations of happiness or beneficial
goods and the motivation of justice in
fact in a well-ordered versity says the
will to justice quote tempers that have
a will to happiness restraining the
wills excesses but there were also being
incompatibilities occasions were one
choose according priority either to
happiness or benefit or to justice one
at the expense of the other in fact the
object of the world that justice is
Ansel tells us at multiple points by its
major involved in interesting and
sometimes even puzzling self-referential
t he says by contrast to the to the will
the will which is towards willing the
beneficial which is not the same thing
that it wills the well which is towards
willing gratitude is rectitude for
nobody wills rectitude without having
rectitude nor can won't someone will it
unless by rectitude bringing God into
the picture adds another dimension to
Hansel's conception of Justice this
enrichment or complication of his moral
theory depending on how you look at it
is inevitable for two main reasons first
is noted earlier Anselm's ontology
including even the being of values is
decidedly Theo centric God is not only
act justly you know but justice
comprises will justice or because they
possess justice to a science degree God
is justice itself all other instances of
justice in some way participating in the
divine justice so presumably any justice
in the human being or will is going to
involve some eventual reference to God
second and some does in fact explicitly
specify justice in relation to God at so
many points in his works that I'm only
going to provide a few representative
passages he says keeping rectitude of
will for the sake of that very rectitude
is for each person to will what God
wills that person to will you rather
convoluted when you first hear it
there's a lot of wills in that sentence
every rational will the creature he said
should be subject to the world of God
that one's a bit more straightforward
every rational creature pose battle
deviants together Rekha tooted well is
present in someone when that person
wills what God wills them to will and
the repetition of that it's not only
that he also has he expresses this in
terms of affections
our motions those who fill their hearts
with love of God neighbor will will
nothing but what God wills for another
person wills as long as this is not
contrary to God these are all ways of
expressing the determinate content of
justice for him and they're all husband
see quite few eccentric so the third
part if one was to select a commonly
referenced moral theory with which to
associate the an songs position at this
point it would not be surprising if it
were either deontological or divine
command ethics many characteristic ants
only an assertion some white sound like
Hachi anism of all of that the absolute
contrast between other goods were useful
the beneficial those we seek through an
interactive will to happiness and the
good of Justice seems much like con
stress on duties absolute priority over
any objects of our desires of
inclination the heterogeneous diversity
of goods desired for it and as
components of a state of happiness that
handsome acknowledges calls to mind
Khan's own suspicions about whether
happiness can even be gattaca Lee
understood let alone enjoy precisely
because it would comprise complete
satisfaction of the beings inclinations
and desires identification of distinctly
moral goodness as justice and handsome
in anseong case resembles cons on
framing as willing not only in
conformity to duty but from duty to
focus on the will and its motives
unwilling justice for its own sake with
the object of maintaining justice within
the will also sounds like Han Xin is
amended evil guard so could ants on via
Concha there are good reasons to answer
no among them the fact that justice and
one's own happiness do remain integrally
and interconnected her handsome and
tucked in contrast to contour stresses
the dissociation between happiness and
unity explaining precisely how this
takes place goes beyond the scope of
this paper but a can be said that the
unavoidably theological dimension of
Anton's theory plays a part in fact this
is another point about this this would
render it hopelessly heteronomous
account in multiple ways not only to
anselm say explicitly that rectitude of
will consists in obedience to the divine
model which would be bad enough from
Khan's perspective he also maintains it
once justice has been abandoned by the
will of a rational being it can only be
restored by God's grace such
considerations raise the possibility
that Hansel's moral theory is best
understood as an example of divine
command ethics there are certainly
ambiguities about precisely one such a
moral theory involves but one generally
agreed-upon characterization is that the
theory renders morality ultimately
dependent on God the divine will or that
will is promulgated in command so that
practically speaking divine revelation
becomes the source for moral standards
and right action involves and is
measured by obedience to conformity with
such revealed commands if all that is
meant by this is that God is the
ultimate origin of goodness or justice
as we've already seen this is true of
excellence theater but divine command
moral theory is typically interpreted as
implying that God can or even does
commanding actions which might seem to
contradict moralities but which by
virtue of being commanded by God thereby
become totally right even obligatory
other typical commitments assert God or
divine revelation to be the exclusive
source of moral standards goodness or
rightness or that human being cannot be
moral without knowing God's revealed
commands recognizing and following them
solely because they are God's commands
not because God happens or necessarily
commands what in fact is good right
moral if we understand divine command
theory along these lines divine command
theory is explicitly rejected by
Handsome in multiple places so the
fourth part does an some whole the
natural law theory what other moral
theory or theories might hansoms be more
closely aligned I absolutely looking at
a few passages we Anselm actually
carries out more reasoning we're worried
mention sources for moral reasoning and
evaluation more suitable candidates will
suggest themselves not surprisingly
anthem does refer to scripture as a
guide for morality in two ways at times
meditation upon the meaning of passages
leads him into drawing out provisions
for the nature and condition of human
being human relations and interactions
with the divine and particularly level
all matters at other times you sites
appropriate passages to provide a basis
an example just too gorgeous to inform a
moral claim or line of argument that
even if any means interestingly and some
places equal weight on authoritative
interpreter subscription of nutrition
life admonishing a fellow bishop for
instance by saying I've quoted a few of
the many authorities if it's a sin to
speak against the Lord and against so
many holy fathers who truly understand
the sayings of the Lord what is it then
act against authorities yeah Ansem is no
fundamentalist or ecclesial
authoritarian what qualifies such
authorities is that they've demonstrated
themselves to have developed genuine
wisdom the state which requires some
moral as well as intellectual progress
in fact faith and reason the divine
order of the natural human intellect are
not radically opposed to each other for
answer and some rights of Scripture as
both containing the authority for every
truth reason it firs since it either
clearly affirms them or it is not in any
way to deny them he asserts that the
Justice 11 want to cultivate can be
called the law of God since it's from
God but also the lot of mine since it's
understood by the mind just as the old
law is called the law of God since it's
from God and the law of Moses since it
was provided through Moses and stoned
himself rarely uses the term natural law
but it would be no stretch to say this
moral theory bears strong affinities
with the natural
theory like that of Thomas Aquinas for
an some all created being is permeated
by the orders of divine providence but
we human beings participate in this and
ways radically transcending those of God
rational beings through our uses of
reason and through our willing both of
which permit us to go astray as well as
rightly so we're called in his view to
employ reason to more and more fully
discerning willingly cooperate with an
order a law a commonly at the complex
least structured normativity which has
its source in the divine but shares its
intelligibility with the human being
seeking to be as it ought to be or as it
was made to be again created human being
he tells us is rational so that it might
discern between the just and the unjust
between the good and the evil and
between the more good and less good
otherwise it would have been made
rational and named by a similar
reasoning he says it's proven that it
received the power of discernment so it
would hate and avoid evil and it would
love and prefer the good even more
greatly loving for further greater good
so reason is is a source for our grasp
of ordering built into that one
consequence of this bears directly on
the human relationship with the divine
through Justice and ordering of goods he
says it's certain that the rational
nature was made for this that it should
love and prefer the supreme good above
everything else and not for the sake of
something else but for its own this bear
is intellectual implications as well the
rational creature ought to apply all of
its capacity and wills remembering
understanding loving the supreme good
for which and he knows
to possess his very being both in
general and indeterminate situations the
human being must employ reason in one
way or another to discern what is good
and bad what ought to be done what want
to be avoided not only in weighing and
ordering various goods but also working
out there concrete arrangements and
implications and forming the will which
ultimately chooses to do this brightly
is not only to strive towards one's
final ed but also to realize what a
human being was made to be and I want to
be in action in willing and thinking and
desires affections emotions even in
relationships in fact full rationality
is not simply a given anymore that is
right volition and the functioning of
both faculties and Foreman influence
each other's development or degeneration
in Hanson's moral theory everything set
so far sounds compatible enough with
Thomas natural law theory but as pointed
out Anselm rarely uses that term and
certainly does not provide us with any
systematically derived some precepts of
the natural law so depending on how one
wants to define that sort of theory and
some may or may not fit last part the
most promising prospect for assigning
Hansel's moral theories actually virtue
at this at least because he handsome
himself speaks in terms of virtue and
vice so often the Admiral is beyond his
biographer tells us that Anselm engaged
in sustained and systematic study in
which he quote uncovered the origins and
so to speak the very seeds and roots and
process of growth of all virtues and
vices and made it clearer than light how
the former could be attained in the
latter avoided or so dude kind of
wishing insolent would have actually
written this down but most of what he
did was oral one might raise a
problematic question though for simply
talking about virtues does not
necessarily entail a commitment to
virtue ethics it would seem that at
least two other things are needed a
thinker would have to articulate a
robust conception of virtues and vices
as developed dispositions reflecting the
character of choice and would also have
to make them central to rather than
in moral life development and evaluation
so does ansel do this well he maintains
that virtues are good mores qualities of
the soul which were unstable now brought
to the condition of habit says they
exist in the soul is stable the virtues
are also products of the human use of
the will right choices and commitments
are both productive of and products
other virtues they are also in
accordance with the virtues conforming
to their patterns and dictates when the
persons will is properly aligned the
soul and its powers are open to doing
what God commands with justice demands
what directly used reason reveals and
song says he says for the soul is open
to the inclination of the virtues and
too willing what should be preferred
memory to the remembering of what lots
of you remember thought to thinking what
ought to be thought upon understanding
to distinguishing what up what should be
will to remember your thought and prefer
eased up to charity is disposed to
humility is strengthened towards
patience and is open to he says the
other virtues that is should that should
be generated now the insulin tells us in
what we do have of his writings much
more about the monastic mode of life
than others but there's no reason to
think that is consistent stress on the
need to inculcate virtues and root out
vices in that mode is not reflective of
a broader attitude applying to all human
beings in a beautiful analogy even makes
virtues central in the right use of
reason he says just as the human body
cannot subsist without frequent
provision of food to it so the soul
cannot live by reason without frequent
engagement with the virtues so the
virtues can be thought of as determinate
ways in which the will to justice
assumes a stable form in the human will
in the soul and human being in the
pattern of his or her life actions and
relationships the will to justice itself
it should be noted can be stronger or
weaker in person and must develop
through willing
actions so that properly structures and
eventually pervades the person's will to
happiness this entire you know complex
of desires that we naturally have
directing the person towards enjoyment
of his or her troop ends one must also
develop the capacity for perseverance
within the world for resisting the
temptation to choose goods incompatible
with justice I kind of fortitude
consisting in willing perseveringly
cleaving constantly are consistently
directed to devote efforts on say in the
end then Anselm's moral theory is most
adequately understood as a virtue ethics
in which justice humility perseverance
and charity are arguably and in
different ways the most architectonic
virtues I'll close of the passage from
one of anthems letters writing is there
gabba to his fellow monks of Beck he
says this is fairly typical of him my
joy in this world is your virtuous life
I pray I beseech you that absent or
present you made gladden my heart by
living virtuously and satisfy my longing
and joy by your business Thank You
secretary well nice to be fit just about
not good nice and time presentation
alright we have about 15 minutes for
questions
it's a sort of traumatic question about
the project as a whole it seems to me
that the conclusion in wave of your
attempts to characterize on some he
doesn't actually fit any of the any of
the categories that contemporary here's
might want to put them in is that right
or am i well I think that it does fit
virtue of us okay I prover true ethics
one integral part of that tradition
anticipo whose whose virtue ethics right
through my characters highly resilient
virtue ethics or domestic virtue ethics
worth you know it's been connected with
the animal law yeah I don't think he
fits he certainly doesn't fit Kant's
version of the anthology which seemed to
view as the exempt are he does it the
divine community clearly says it says no
on that natural law is kind of a tough
fit all those a lot of good alignments
ethics of care is actually the
attractive one because ants on focuses
so much on the emotions relationships
and how those want to be structured
especially on love and caring but the
academic category
but virtue ethics he does but virtue
ethics you think of like McIntyre's
bringing virtue ethics where virtue
ethics cannot just be some some category
by itself to the exclusion of these
other theories it has to incorporate
what's best in them going back to
Aristotle yeah anthem is doing something
like that so the elements of other
theories like the focus very strong
focus on the will and rectitude kept for
its own sake which looks like the
anthology would have to be incorporated
into make it work if the reason I had
actually question is I was considering
the possibility that week on some theory
is just soo generis in which case trying
to patient hole in a certain way might
might detract from the statements of
review some of the people who've written
there's not an awful lot out there
seemed to interpret him like that but
what I want what I want to do is to sort
of bring him into the folder virtue
ethics and say that he is you know one
of the things that we often forget in
part because when we look at the
medievals those of us that are
interested and I think to focus much
more on scholastic philosophy and
theology
theology guys against on the left out of
the picture although they were
incredibly in flushing throughout the
villages even on the Scholastic walkers
so I had one of her handsome back into
the fold right and the larger project of
the rent or enhancements and so you're
getting almost message talking points
and it's not particularly well supported
so I checkin i just put forward a
distinction we showed out new talking
about the end of an action there are
three ways until you at the end and just
before totally went together well what
you wanted farther hey who's the coffee
yeah for for what you wanted with
yourself and how you want to drink well
the drinking is is the way well I yeah
so what do you want I want a cup of
coffee but I want it for me to drink
yeah right typically in missoula
criticized very very especially in the
case of Arizona client and the notion of
happiness things they say well this is
too selfish to cell phone
and they're accusing them of
distinguishing the talking who we write
that you pursue the good which could the
good that's good to me that's my
happiness yeah so the the what you're
desiring is subordinated to me it's
being what it is they're you running put
it everything good for handsome that too
is a terrible if you desire theatre me
that the Apple the computer well
actually he says there's good and bad
computer sucks but but nevertheless it's
still desiring for me and samus is fine
with goods for me with him it's a
question of the bordering guts right and
he would regular virtue ethics so people
have been debating as Aristotle in the
egoist I think that that's not a useful
way to frame it because in order to
enjoy happiness and any full sense you
have to be sharing it with other people
so you can't be so since I would you
enough surely for you Jaron goodness
with other people that's what happened
it's real yep but but surely as you
mentioned yeah the crucial thing is the
love of justice yes that's what you
should do and does he say full of the
devil devil's problem was to regard god
that's a good self being like God yeah
we're right okay but many love God whose
love of concupiscence no love just that
right well he talks about the will to
happiness yeah the anthem doesn't use
the language of concupiscence we don't
want as far as I can tell and the devil
screwed up by loving by wanting by
desiring the best good you could
possibly manage to be like God and what
himself well it's not that it's that it
was for himself Anselm says he desired
it inordinately because it's not a bad
thing to want that for yourself if
that's all says if we said that being
Jesus Christ would be bad
alright so it's more a matter of
invisible I think again it's Anselm
there's a lot more similarities to
Richard's the will to justice he says
tempers the wealthy happiness so the X
upon all these these inclinations and
desires that we have and it's
strengthens them nada gives them to get
to focus on diversity at the right time
for the right reason to the right degree
the ancyl doesn't use that language per
se and you have to dig it to do a lot of
digging around to find examples lighter
areas in this passage of that passage
but I think you can put them together
systematically it's very much like like
that picture okay well maybe Mike Mike I
come in to look right I was trying to
push it because you wanted more like hot
well I i think this distinction is far
more crucial for themselves than it is
in Arizona Aquinas even though it's not
denied by them but but this is crucial
to him in a way that you don't find it
in in virtue it but you know
organization Rockets a dispute the
rumble yeah I've been loving yourself
properly doing understanding what ought
to be for you what what is your
legitimate good is sorry transom sure
the question is not that this is
effectual this is ok they have is that
ethics is really that loving the good in
this case God corazon same regardless
and that's easily important it is unseen
attacks in Sarasota [ __ ] anyone and
it's fake in Einstein's and well in
Aristotle's 13 aerosol in a minutes okay
bit dodgy inquired Fagin and so its
bigger discours yeah that's what I was
in for right so I'm trying to say that
he's not he's the virtue and says he's
not in your house feeling
yeah I'd agree with that you'd have to
do a lot of pushing together okay we
have one person any other Chris oh look
thirsty thing you said that a song
rejected divine command theory yes and
then earlier you said maybe I miss the
connection of disconnect when person or
persons wills what God wills and the
well yes that person is is doing that's
that's right into the world yes how is
that every time I take the divine of
divine command I take the divine command
theory to be going beyond just saying
that a person will want to be aligned a
little God any natural law theory says
that as well divine command theory that
I gathered this is chemic loosey-goosey
tourism means different kinds of
different people it tends to get invoked
is the notion that God is the sole
source commands rules those sorts of
things but so long as you follow those
rules you're here okay if god were to
change those rules tomorrow that would
be okay too because it's got an Ansel
considers issues like that incurred is
home all the personal og on moto g into
to a certain extent
work and he says well that wouldn't be
God that if God were to actually wants
to change the rules of the game what
counts is right wrong that wouldn't you
got something else not as it is
following his own nature than the day
libertagia could duck God take away
justice from a person and some says nope
once a person has justice and will not
even God because why is that a
restriction on God no because God
wouldn't do that sort of thing god never
command something that went against the
goodness that God already knows the
divine command theory that we insert an
academic category as we've often gets
plot it sounds as if well God can switch
things up if he likes that's what I'm
saying Anselm objective that's why he's
not oh one of the mean you've been
contrasting and salvia be with the other
people and basically saying he's not
like this in those respects we haven't
had an awful lot of a positive account I
did anticipate that you are heading
toward virtue theory actually fairly
early yeah but it seems to me that there
is one question that's this sort of
outstanding here he also adds home seems
to be regressive Neoplatonism that he in
a very funny way yeah well he's
definitely identifying God as sort of
the source or defining basis of justice
particularly and maybe secondarily other
goods to god is he is a neo Plagueis in
that every one of the divine attributes
is something within which other things
participate so God is the goodness by
which other things
necessary God is the truth by which all
of interests are truthful we've known el
Ghazi the life through ajantans okay
that's that's what I suspected oh well
again you can pick them different virtue
theories maybe that's a slight
exaggeration but one one notorious
problem for virtue theory is it tends to
provide no account for why virtues
specific virtues are good it just stops
there often times yeah or or it actually
defeats itself by peeling to something
and becomes in a sense something other
than virtue theory so if a choose really
promotes happiness than in an ultimate
sense we have a kind of heating as a
lawyer or utilitarian or are you
diamonds yeah yeah well right and
Catherine Rogers actually thinks Anselm
is a you die monistic theory I have an
extra fiver well so my question is
simply this i guess if if he's primarily
a virtue theorist and he is adding
another component here and that is a
basis for virtue in god and then there's
any of that i mean and i agreed that i
don't think it's the body command theory
certainly in the standard way but there
is still a basis of all virtue in God's
nature so is God ultimately the basis or
defining explanation of all virtue or
are we going to take virtue theory more
like virtue is imitating God that oh
well both transom I mean okay he says is
the prettiest home Christ actually gives
us some examples safer humility but then
he unpacks it in a couple different
places and kicked on in data- marvelous
and also along
consistent analysis we put together and
he's not just referring to God like that
like i said in here i think all the
virtues for Hansel can be conceived of
as determinants ways in which the will
to justice takes shape fixed you know
takes hold of the human bill it's a
stable form so they're all they're all
ultimately ways of willing justice the
right relationship to God for its own
sake then one's self possibly just
supers you know so proposing it on the
building a POS possibly contradicting
are both happens when you curb our our
designers or things like that I don't
know that that that turns them into the
lawn is being virtues no I'm really
without much kind of virtue theory and a
demoniac seat yeah yeah global question
quickly whenever a widget so that's
because for this actually very good
folks over later to when you were
talking about it seems to me that if I
understood you correctly that I had some
justice played central for these central
you say that right what I think so what
I'd like to do is to try get some some
clear grasp of what justice is handsome
especially if you want to make him a
non-virtue at a person was a loser
ascribes to virtue ethics but does it in
a way by underpinning these Russians
with justice which would make him no
longer and avoid Stratasys but at least
then you would have a basis when the
other merchants here's my question SI is
it well first of all just as a central
yeah and and God is justice and
everything and everything else it is
just is just by virtue of participe one
is generously but not necessarily
directly as if there's just God and
everything directly / space of God I
don't care what we how directly or
indirectly God is forced to be just as
right I want to get a grip on what
justice is because I don't know what God
so that doesn't help me is David Carlyle
I mean some of the implications of
cancels doctors we don't in fact know
what justice in its fullest sense is any
more than we know of reason in its full
of senses because it is gone so we have
sort of intimation ours are always
thinking always get better and better
does that present is not very
destructive conclusion to come to the
fore know and so it is fact alien
because well we can't know what justice
is there's difference because there's a
different change made other we have
troops and we can know there's a
difference between not knowing period
and not fully done but they give me some
sense of what justice is limestone sure
again what's his definition of it
willing rectitude of will cut for its
own sake so being thrown into a
determinate situation in which you have
to stick to what what you want to do as
opposed to say you're including what you
want to do those we could be defined by
what justice is no I don't know what
that yeah he's he's he's not providing
anything like a foundational here's the
three axioms of it and then it goes from
no I just want to understand so yeah PS
got it to him he can't he can't flinging
around terms loosely without defining
them in some she does angela well then
that's a real problem yeah so because
you
you can't get a grip on what justices
and then if rectitude of will will how
do you be one God always being always
being steadfastly willing what is just
but again I don't know what that is but
how do you learn what it would have hurt
you is anyway it's not somebody coming
up to you and saying here's the
definition I'll just do this it's your
practice through being embedded in some
sort of milieu so if you want examples
of all the different things if you want
examples of where handsome gives
instances he says he hears the just
thing here's the unjust thing here's why
it's just her son just there's a lot of
individual examples and letters and
little bits here and there the trees is
even arguably in his prayers yeah this
is one of the challenges he doesn't can
ever if he in fact did is he on arsenio
uncovered the very roots and sources of
the virtues and vices he didn't write it
down for something like a treatise but
what if you've got these examples of
time sure what could be roughly what
would be them that would be an inductive
approach then too okay she likely well
as well right yeah you know what I'm
pushing this point that is give us
something yeah and it would actually it
might actually presuppose what you're
trying to prove here but you can say
that's just as that social time justice
all right maybe not maybe you can just
say well this is a certain kind of
action that's similar to that kind of
action to this kind of action and what
they haven't
is this thing and I'm going to call that
javis especially yeah you'll find left
oh well I have more to think about I
guess ok go down well that's